[Music]
now one of the more remarkable speeches
at last week's Tory Party Conference was
made uh by the Home Secretary s bravman
in which she talked about luxury beliefs
uh which is a phrase I believe coined by
Rob Henderson the uh American academic
um but it's also something that our next
guest Matt Goodwin um talks about Matt
has a new book called values voice and
virtue uh and Matt you've written quite
a lot about this subject uh can you
define for us first of all for anyone
who hasn't um heard the term before what
luxury beliefs are and why they
represent an opportunity for the Tory
party yeah sure uh luxury beliefs really
refer to ideas or views which infer
status on members of the elite which
bring members of the elite few costs but
which impose very heavy costs on other
people so an example of a luxury belief
might be uh members of the political
media cultural class calling for large
scale immigration because they're the
least likely to suffer the negative
effects of that but we know from
research workingclass non-graduate
voters are the most like
to suffer the effects of that or
similarly calling for a more relaxed
approach to family whereas we know
members of the the elite are the most
likely to get married stay married and
have children within marriage it's
everybody else that suffers from the
collapse of of those guard rails so
luxury belief is luxury beliefs are
really about the sort of hypocrisy that
lie at the the heart of uh some people
in the elite and for the conservative
party when it comes to issues like
migration
diversity identity family crime uh some
prominent uh uh politicians SW braan
included clearly think that there's some
political Capital to be had by zooming
in on some of those
contradictions do you think perhaps
there isn't as much political Capital as
perhaps so Bradman thinks because we've
just had the labor party conference and
uh I think it's quite clear that kir
starmer is is playing down that sort of
politics uh he's trying not to talk even
if issues are Salient he's not talking
about them or he's dismissing them as
populism without getting too stuck in
them I I think there's another view
which is you know labor are playing a
very risky game when it comes to these
these issues because you know look since
the the brexit referendum we were often
told that that voters don't really care
about these these issues around
immigration and identity anymore well we
know that that's not true we know that
for example migration both legal and
illegal is back to being the third most
important issue for all voters and the
most important issue for those 2019
conservative voters who only last week
rated it above the economy which is
really quite remarkable when you
consider we're in the most severe cost
of living crisis for half a century and
even still many of those voters who of
course left labor for Boris Johnson are
saying that for them immigration is is
still a Paramount issue so for labor and
K sta to downplay
that issue to essentially not talk about
it during the labor conference there's a
little bit of discussion about you know
smashing the gangs but there wasn't
really a sort of serious discussion
about either how to bring down legal
migration or how to actually um prevent
illegal migration over the longer term
um I would argue that's a very risky
political strategy for labor and leaves
a conservatives you know with a big
opening if they can if they can find a
way to to kick a football into to
it um and what about I mean obviously
migration is a huge one and as you point
out there is there is some Capital there
for the Tories politically um but on
other issues do you think it's fair to
say that the the slur of populism that
is more uh effective than it is perhaps
in America because we often hear it said
and it's it's not just an elite opinion
we often hear said that Brit Brits don't
particularly like these issues coming
into politics they don't like you know
woke issues they don't like
transgenderism as a political subject it
turns them off uh in both directions
left and
right I you know I don't find that
particularly convincing I mean if you
look at the issues that we often refer
to as as quote unquote culture wars
these issues are often actually very
Central to the way in which people think
about their lives immigration is a great
example about 75% of people would like
to lower overall migration they think
it's been too high over the last decade
uh they think it's been badly managed if
you look for example at gender issues
well in Scotland when people began to
look at the gender recognition Reform
Bill they became really interested in it
and of course 80% said this is a
terrible idea if you look at issues like
crime uh the British public are
consistently more hard lined than both
uh labor and conservative politicians
and if you look at issues like political
correctness or or you know woke ideology
um you know that again is is something
concerns about 60% of Brits who say they
feel in today's climate they can't
really say what they want to to say so I
I don't buy the argument that uh you
know so-called culture wars which by the
way you know these issues are often
foundational to to who we are the rights
of family the rights of women sex-based
rights history identity you know this is
all pretty Central stuff I I I don't
think you can just push this out of
politics I think this is now in the
center of politics and in the public
square and so that's why we saw Rishi
sunak in Manchester make explicit
reference to these issues in his speech
now a Critic would say he was also
rather vague about what he wanted to do
you know he said a woman is a woman a
man is a man well does that mean the
conservatives are going to do what the
Republicans have done in terms of
intervening in schools and universities
and and you know soel braan what she
said and I've pulled it is very popular
in the country 66% of all Brits think
that mass immigration is an existential
challenge to the West but what are the
actual policies that the conservatives
are going to introduce are they going to
reduce legal migration are they going to
increase the salary thresholds that are
currently allowing I would argue um too
much low School migration are they going
to clamp down on International students
and their dependence in a more long-term
sustainable way you know these are all
things that we don't really have the
answers to so it's difficult for the
conservatives to outflank labor on
migration because they they haven't
really gone all in when it comes to
delivering a policy that would act
actually meet uh a majority of British
voters where they are so it makes it
very difficult for the conservatives
there is an opportunity but they have to
bring the policies forward to seize it
you're quite custic about the term
cultur Wars there and I and I get what
you mean but isn't that precisely what
you're getting at there that for a lot
of Voters uh if it's just talk if it's
just uh headlines and the odd statement
um by the Tories about stopping the
boats or uh pro- family or whatever um
if if there aren't any serious pro-
family policies put in place um then
voters don't really care either way what
either part is
saying voters are very disillusioned
across the board I recently pulled um uh
a big nationally representative sample
of Voters and I ask them what are the
issues that you feel really concerned
about but also feel you're not
represented on number one was
immigration most people want it lowered
most people want it slowed down neither
of the parties are committed to that
number two was politic IAL correctness
people feeling like they cannot say what
they think neither party is seriously
committed to rooting out uh this sort of
stifling um you know Progressive
ideology so-called Progressive ideology
in the institutions which has left so
many people feeling as though they can't
really say what they they want want want
to say and the third was promoting
Britain's distinctive identity history
and culture against what many people
feel as a sort of bland globalization
Universal liberal ideology that sort of
celebrates diversity but isn't really
all that interested in the distinctive
things about Britain the things that
make us British or English or Welsh or
Scottish and and those are the things
that people really do feel animated
about and all politics is about supply
and demand and I think in Britain what
we've got at the moment is actually lots
of public demand for a different kind of
politics but we don't have much Supply
we don't have either labor or the
conservative party really meeting voters
on those on those issues and so this big
consensus that we have a kind of big
State uh High tax uh kind of low
productivity High
immigration um you know London Centric
economy still it is alienating a lot of
Voters they do want to talk about these
issues they do want to talk about what
their kids are being taught around sex
gender and race they do want to talk
about the constant revision of British
history they do care about these things
about their shared identity they also
care about the cost of living they also
care about housing but I simply don't
buy the argument that these are Fringe
issues which politicians shouldn't talk
about because if you want to see one
politician and you know this much better
than me Fred if you want to see one
politician who's Riding High in the poll
still and who's talking a lot about this
where you look at America and you can
see with the Republicans and the current
polling that they are still actually
holding together the post 20106
realignment if you look at how strongly
supportive workingclass voters are of um
Donald Trump non-graduates pensioners
small Towners Suburban women all the
groups by the way that the British
Tories have managed to alienate and lose
over the last uh few years certainly
since 2019 the Republicans are actually
in play I mean they've still got that
realignment and irrespective of how you
feel about Donald Trump as a as a case
study of how to hold together a
coalition and by the way they've also
eaten into Hispanic Latino voters in a
significant way you know they've done
that partly by leaning into many of
these cultural questions by actually
recognizing that voters want to have a
conversation about the things that make
them who they who they are their history
their identity their culture what we
teach our children uh now whether the
British Tories decide to step into that
not not necessarily saying they should
become a trumpian party but if they
become a more interventionist party on
these issues a more culturally
conservative party that's willing to
actually have a conversation with the
country about these issues then I
suspect they will have a lot more room
for maneuver um in at the elections to
come I suppose it's quite a difficult
thing to prove uh but it seems to me
from a from an observational point of
view that uh the more popular these
issues become with the public the more
uh the progressive ruling class uh who
hold these luxury opinions um Harden in
their views and I think we see that
within the conservative party of it's
not that the conservatives disagree
necessarily it's just that they
associate with a sort of politics they
find ugly and probably in a snobbish
sense because this is to a large extent
a class
division yeah well I think that's spot
on I think if you you know why is it
that the British Tories unlike
conservatives in Italy Sweden France and
America have actually been very
reluctant to get involved it doesn't
take you long in the Tory movement to
find somebody who's critical of soel
braan I mean what she's come out and
said has actually been quite unpopular
around the cabinet table why is that
because their status conscious Tories I
mean they are they view cultural issues
as being beneath them uh they view
issues around migration and and
integration and sex and gender and
history and statues you know all this
stuff is kind of you know low brow it's
not status driven politics and that's
where they're missing a trick I mean
that's where they are really struggling
and if you look at the 2019 electorate
that rallied around Boris Johnson you
know wanting lower migration stronger Bo
orders tough approach on crime promoting
Britain's distinctive identity in
history which you know we've seen over
the last three and four years be
consistently eroded by the advance of
radical
progressivism uh the conservatives are
only holding about 60% of that vote now
so you know that 40% has basically left
the party a big chunk gone to labor a
big chunk gone to reform um but a big a
chunk has said you know I'm not going to
vote at the next election I'm completely
disillusioned and so what I often say to
Cabinet ministers and I said to one last
week is you know we are now in a world
where voters basically want security
they and they don't just want Economic
Security from the cost of living crisis
from the uh from the declining living
standards they don't just want physical
security from a collapsing National
Health Service they don't just want um
National Security from small boats from
rising immigration from culturally
different groups who we've seen this
week protesting and supporting the
atrocity
in in Israel on the Streets of London
they also want cultural security they
want cultural security from this
oppressive stifling Orthodoxy which has
left them feeling as though well if they
don't agree with radical progressives on
on pro-immigration PR globalization
pro-social liberalism they're going to
be outcast you know they might lose
their jobs or they might be silenced and
I think this cultural security notion is
one that's going to become increasingly
Central to our politics especially given
the fact that 85 to 90% of Voters in
Britain really do feel very strongly
attached to Britain they feel proud of
the country they um they view their
national identity as a key part of who
they are that's not like the people who
dominate many of the institutions they
it's not to say they don't like Britain
but they don't attach as much importance
to their national identity so this Rift
is going to become still I think much
more Central to our politics as we
navigate the 2020s and Beyond at Matt uh
just as a matter of curiosity have you
in all of your polling picked up a
strong desire uh in among the British
public to ban smoking for young
people um not consistently I mean I've
not pulled it um extensively myself and
I've not not focus grouped it but if you
look at some of the polling that we have
had since the ban um youav uh I think
I'm right in saying fine that a
plurality of supportive of the ban um
minority oppose it um but I've not done
any uh detailed work on it but probably
fair to say it's not a priority for
British voters oh it's it's no it's not
a priority at all and actually one of
the things I wrote about in uh on on my
substat was about um you know sunx
speech was bizarre for that reason which
is if you look at the top three issues
for all voters in the country number one
is cost of living number two is NHS and
number three is migration and migration
is both legal and illegal um and the
problem is you know he decided to focus
on the smoking ban a levels and a train
line into Northern England and these are
just not Salient issues for the country
and I wonder why he went so far off the
grid in his conference speech and when
you compare and contrast that to K
stamas I have to say even though starma
played down immigration which I
mentioned was risky he did at least talk
a lot about the salian issues about the
cost of living crisis about the state of
the NHS about housing about some of
these really big tanic issues and I
think sunak you know I understand the
strategy of being more compatitive but
he's got to get back to those top three
issues very
quickly probably status stbon um Matt
thank you very much indeed uh everyone
should read your new book uh values
voice and virtue uh and please come on
spectator TV again
soon
thanks
[Music]